he's going out and then he's coming in a
it in other words he's
settling I know that already this is
going to be a hard wall so pet pushes
in if it feels what I call firm it's a
hard
ball and that means that Ray wants to
achieve it that means he's individual
that means he's
nag it's really difficult to say but
surely he wants to achieve it doesn't he
I'm going but then he can't be okay he's
got to be nag so as long as he's happy
being nag then that means that even when
he gets old he's going to be a fearsome
old chat because he's going to be he's
still going to
win go to be not
I'm
exactly so I'm looking at a lot of you
and this and the hard wall is there but
what's happening is what's happening is
you're not you're not wanting to admit
it you're sort of like just watch a
little bit of that or or where the hand
is just a little bit of that see I'm
seeing changes what you want is is if a
butterflyes just landed it's really
delicate you feel so if I put my hand
blade there because I was asked this
question a moment ago it feels different
that than the hand blade than that and
I'm going they're all hard
balls because he shouldn't feel any
different
between
that that and that and when you push
in It's
s because I'm not try but if I go no
he's going to make he's going to show me
up me I feel that hardness coming in so
the hardness is in through you wanting
to still win
right as I say if you pick it up today
then well God I'll charge you ,000 each
because that's amaz um but you know it's
food for you to
consider let's say
again you
comes whatever you want to
do there soft soft walls they still
there isn't it yeah or I could
my mask you see now he got a hard one
I've still got him but the difference is
I'm not trying to over
take Rim Andy you're not ready for Rim
Andy just yet so we'll stick with the
madori you you're you got to be careful
because you're getting into
the yeah okay you're getting into the
training mode you're just doing it
you're not spending enough time
am I in the right place or not no I'm
not in the right place even though it's
a soft wall I don't feel like I'm in the
wrong right place but I don't know where
the right place is I mean I do but I'm
just telling you what I'm hoping you're
going to be thinking so because I'm in
the wrong place is when he pushes in see
they felt that hard
more it weren't because I was trying it
was because I was in the wrong
place so if the angle wrong comes sharp
if the angle's right it becomes
soft say the angan your body angle to
them yeah your body angle to them I
could be at the same
angle I've changed the angle cuz he
changed my angle see so when you push
soft isn't it yeah and oh I I was about
I was about there try it again yeah see
hard talking about centimeters aren't we
but you see because I didn't move where
I wanted to he moved me I moved to the
right place so that's where I'm hoping
you're going to one day go or at least
go oh I felt
that but I don't know how to repeat it
then it means you've got to spend longer
working on your intuition
so
completely uh so there lots of things I
think these does are you go
by you know the Old Gentleman thing is
oh please after you but there's a case
of uh after
you well how much more woman would you
want me to
move saying like you can go by me
they're not really giving that or
there's you know where
he distance
my my he can't get me I can't get him
okay so let's try again MOA Dory when
you do it slow enough then I'm going to
get you to do MOA and show them at the
moment you're in training mode you're
not in search
mode SP you need to spend longer asking
yourself the right place but don't know
it be you need to you need to start
questioning whether it feels better
sense wise six sense
but you know it's just an intuition
you've got to find out understand do you
feel in a better place this time than
you did last or you still lost if you
want to try a few angles then it's going
back to you isn't it so you've got to
work they working you you're not working
you